es el primer paso para investigar
crímenes de guerra en palestina una sala
preliminar de la corte penal
internacional determinó que palestina es
un estado parte del tribunal y que
abarca los territorios ocupados por
israel incluyendo cisjordania jerusalén
del este y la franja de gaza
la aclaración es una respuesta a la
solicitud de la fiscal general fatou
bensouda que pidió a la sala especificar
los territorios donde pueden llevarse a
cabo investigaciones la autoridad
nacional palestina que solicitó una
investigación formal en 2018 celebró la
medida
la resolución es un mensaje para los
perpetradores de crímenes que sus
crímenes no estarán sujetos a un
estatuto de limitaciones y que no
quedarán impunes israel que no hace
parte de la corte ni reconoce su
jurisdicción denunció una supuesta
persecución legal un dios diciendo esto
siguiendo la cpi investiga israel por
crímenes de guerra falsos eso es puro
antisemitismo como primer ministro de
israel les aseguro que vamos a combatir
esta perversión de justicia con todas
nuestras fuerzas
estados unidos a través del departamento
de estado apoyo a su aliado israel y
expresó su preocupación sobre la
decisión de la cpi palestina espera que
se investiguen los excesos cometidos por
las fuerzas israelíes en la represión de
las llamadas marchas del retorno de 2018
que dejaron al menos 270 palestinos
muertos y más de 16.000 heridos
y también los bombardeos en la franja de
gaza- en 2014
sin una fuerza policial propia la cpi
depende de la voluntad de los estados
por lo que es poco probable que israel
entregue voluntariamente a posibles
sospechosos además el tribunal también
podría investigar a miembros de grupos
armados palestinos que son mencionados
en los informes de la fiscal